نحن في حي في استهدف هذا المكان وهذا
المركز التجاري بقذائف قبل قليل وصواريخ
كما يمكن مشاهده حجم الدمار في هذا المبنى
وفق المعطيات الاوليه ان شخصا قتل واخر
جرح يمكن ايضا ان نشاهد حجم هذا الدمار
المحققون في الموقع يقومون بتدقيق لمعرفه
نوع الصواريخ التي استخدمت في هذا
الاستهداف اذا ما اقتربنا هذا احد الذين
او القتيل الذي سقط في هذا القصف الذي
استهدف هذه المنطقه قبل قليل السكان
تحدثوا عن لحظات رعب عاشها الاهالي الذين
يعيشون في محيط هذه المنطقه اذا ما روينا
اللحظات الاولى لهذا القصف دوت اربع
انفجارات في سماء وسط مدينه دانيتك ناتجه
عن تصدي الدفاعات الجويه هذه التاريخ في
وسط مدينه ثم تلاها قصف مكثف على مختلف
الاحياء السكنيه في هذه المدينه بعد
الصواريخ سقط في هذه المنطقه في كييف يمكن
ان نشاهد ايضا الى جانب هذا المركز
التجاري هذا المبنى السكني التي لحقته
الاضرار ودمرت عدن من الشقق فيه الزجاج
محشم والاهالي بطبيعه الحال تم اخلائهم من
هذه المنطقه بشكل كامل يجري احصاء الاضرار
كما اشرت للتعامل معها في الساعات المقبله
كارمنج خضر الجزيره